first and foremost I wanted to say you
know thank you and apologies for me not
being able to be there in person due to
some family issues and so you know what
could possibly go wrong with this
technology right yeah so uh so here we
go really this is a tremendous
opportunity for me to speak to to you a
group that I normally don't speak to and
hopefully I can present to you kind of
uh some grand challenges here regarding
space and and this idea of space traffic
so I'm gonna share some slides with you
and I'm sure it's all gonna work out
quite nicely and we'll just see how this
goes all right so here we go it's
advance the slides here yeah so the
research program that I heat have here
at UT Austin really focuses on three
major areas the larger circles we focus
on information sources and you can think
of these as you know sensor measurements
from things like radars and telescopes
and also human based information tweet
semantics type stuff things that you can
find on the internet and we're really
interested in as much information as we
can gather about stuff in space so the
other area that we really focus on is
system behavior and we're looking at
sensor systems and then the actual
systems that are on space whether
they're satellites that are actually
working or pieces of space junk and I'm
going to describe to you what I mean by
space junk here in a little bit and then
the last area of research it's like okay
so there's stuff in space and there's
stuff that we are observing so what
and that part is the knowledge
extraction quantification and assessment
so those are the three areas of research
activity but if you had to ask me
alright dude so like what do you
actually do I would say those are the
smaller circles so we're really in the
business of developing models about all
these things that we can give back to
the public for public good I like to put
things in terms of Venn diagrams because
you know it's it's simple for me to
understand that way and I want you to
think about all this is the set of all
events and processes that are actually
occurring in space that's the large
circle and for a variety of reasons that
entire set of events and processes is
unknown you can't know everything it
turns out I no surprise to many folks in
the crowd I'm sure and out of the set of
all the stuff that's happening there's a
subset of things that we measure which
I'm going to call evidence and then we
have a subset of things that we call
beliefs or hypotheses and if we're
really lucky the stuff that we believe
or hypothesized coincides with stuff
that we measure and I'm going to call
that inferred knowledge so so one of the
things I tell my students is if you want
to know something you have to measure it
and if you want to understand something
you have to be able to predict it
I would probably say and and some of you
might think I'm joking but several times
a month I get people that are emailing
me about the Flat Earth okay and so what
I tell them is if the earth is actually
flat your hypothesis has to explain all
past observations and it has to be able
to predict the future and so far they
haven't been able to demonstrate that to
me
so an ideal world here love for all
these three circles to coincide exactly
but they don't and and and and so that's
part of our problem there's stuff that's
happening in space that we just don't
know we don't understand all right to
give you some more context here it turns
out that White House signed this thing
called space policy directive number
three and I'm not going to read the
whole thing to you but just to say that
there are all these capabilities that we
depend on in space like position
navigation timing location services
making a lot of satellites now route
banking information weather warnings
you've seen with you know hurricane and
typhoons you know getting these warnings
ahead of time and soon even the internet
itself is going to be a space-based
service and so nothing is really
protecting any of these services from
any harm from loss disruption or
degradation and so National Space policy
is saying hey we really depend on space
need to do something about being able to
monitor all that space and hopefully
come up with a set of the space traffic
rules that all those can abide by
because as it turns out we don't have
any space traffic rules today as as wild
as that may seem
so in this next chart to give you a
better idea of kind of what we're
talking about NASA has an orbital degree
program office at Johnson Space Center
in Houston where did they put together a
couple of plots the one that you see to
your left that shows something that
looks like it's growing unfortunately
that is the number of of tracked objects
since we started launching things since
Sputnik and right now we currently track
about 26,000 objects ranging in size
from your cell phone all the way up to
the space station and some satellites
are like school buses but we don't track
anything really smaller than that and
unfortunately we believe that they're
probably about half a million objects
that could harm a satellite that go all
the way down in size to a speck of paint
and so unfortunately a speck of paint
moving at the right speed that collides
against something that works it actually
render it useless and so that's part of
this tragedy that we face in space this
orbital iceberg of sorts the next slide
here is really painting a little little
bleak of a picture in the sense that we
have a couple of people that want to
provide global internet with satellites
and they plan on launching lots of stuff
in the next five or so years so I told
you that we track the total of 26,000
objects what I didn't tell you is that
currently out of the 26,000 objects only
about 2,500 are things that work and
everything else is garbage and you
actually plan on launching about 10 to
15,000 satellites within the next 5
years so
and this gives you an idea of the number
of satellites the the company the
altitude and what what year okay so
we're gonna see this a little bit better
here here here you can see some of the
clusters of where they want to put these
objects based on their altitude so
number of satellites versus orbital up
altitude and when these things overlap
each other that's that's definitely
something we need to be concerned about
so things that enable space traffic
management you really want space to be
transparent so we want to know where
everything is at and where everything
will be hopefully and we'd like to
stimulate that with people be able being
able to talk to each other we be
culturally competent because it turns
out different cultures manifest
themselves differently in space in terms
of behavior for instance if you wanted
to know when US satellites and louver
their satellites when you know whenever
they change orbits Americans usually do
that on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays because you know weekends and
holidays we don't like to work on those
days and you don't want to do them an
uber on a Friday because Murphy's Law
says that sometimes bad things happen
and things don't work out right so you
don't want to stay home I mean stay at
work late and you certainly don't want
to have to think about doing this we
first come back from your weekend but
that's American culture but not all
cultures behave the same way and we
really need to get a better handle on
the physics of what's going on in space
so essentially ingredients for space
traffic we need an independent way to
monitor stuff I think maybe some people
in the room maybe heard that India blew
up one of their own satellites earlier
in the year and this created a bunch of
debris and some of that debris is still
on orbit and people from India
you know the Jedi mind-trick those
aren't the droids you're looking for
sort of in all that debris is gonna come
back within 45 days except that there
are other people that say no in fact
there's a lot of debris that's gonna be
out there for decades so who do you
believe I you know I don't have I don't
have the evidence to infer that on my
own people in the room probably don't
have that evidence and so there needs to
be an independent way to keep people
honest and monitor this stuff okay we
need to have sustainability metrics we
need to develop best practices and
standards so back to one of the things
that I said earlier you can't manage
what you don't know and you don't know
what you don't measure people want to
know what normal behavior is in space
people want to attribute cause to an
anomaly if my satellite stops working
was it because the Sun had a hiccup and
there was extra energy that upset the
electronics or was it Jimmy
who really can't stand me and did
something and schwag me when I wasn't
looking it's very difficult to figure
that out because space is not
ubiquitously and persistently monitored
and and not everybody is sharing
information so that's part of this idea
of wanting a crowdsource information if
possible to make things a little bit
worse there is a here's real data from a
telescope called the Space Surveillance
telescope it's currently in Australia
and all the dots that you see our
detection at the telescope was made on a
single night one single nights worth of
detecting stuff so the good news about
the space surveillance telescope is that
it detects lots of stuff and the bad
news about the space surveillance
telescope is that it detects lots of
stuff
so all the dots that you see that are
black are things that were detected that
we believe we know what they are and
every dot up there that's not black is
basically a UFO we have no idea what
that is that's you know st. Louis we
have a problem and so you know which one
of the the non black dots is something
that could be hazard that could harm you
yeah so so so this is this is one of the
things that kind of keeps me up at night
is figuring this out this background
clutter so this is part of the challenge
I'm posing to you we'll get to exactly
what it is I'm going to request from you
here soon we talked about detecting and
tracking some people try to use those
words interchangeably I'm just gonna say
this just detecting isn't good enough
you have to be able to track tracking
means detecting and uniquely identifying
you want to do both you wanna you want
to detect stuff and and know it's
identity and so if somebody says well
really what show me the difference okay
there it is that's the difference
between detecting stuff and tracking
stuff the stuff that's tracked is black
and the stuff that is just detected
isn't and so another way to say that is
imagine if we had a bucket of detections
we have some sensor that detects stuff
at three different times
most of the stuff up there doesn't
report its identity so how do we solve
that identity crisis how do we combine
information manage it exploit it do big
data science analytics that sort of
stuff maybe apply some machine learning
AI to try to reverse engineer what the
identity of all these things in space
are
part of the problem ideally what we'd
love to do is start from way on the left
with the thing that we measure these are
all different things that we can measure
and we'd like to move towards the right
to say what combination of things that
we measure gives me insight into
physical properties of these objects
what combination of those physical
properties gives me insights of
functional properties and operational
properties and then even further to the
right can I then classify these objects
into different species and maybe even
get to you know a one-to-one kind of
identity
that's what I'd love to be able to do
I'd love for you folks to help me do
that so this is going to be a bit busy
certainly the people that are way way up
on top cover your left eye and right now
I'm just joking so we we use these
things call ontology z' or schema and
what we'd like to be able to do is using
graph databases kind of superimpose
these schema and on top or ontology z'
on the graph database to make this into
a knowledge graph where we can then
semantically link all these different
parts of participants and contributors
to what's going on in the space domain
so we can discover some stuff because we
need to be in that business of
discovering and so one of the things
that we've done here is we have a
three-tiered kind of process we have
instance data different sources of
information which I'll actually show you
what I'm talking about here in a little
bit from the United States Department of
Defense from Russia from some commercial
satellite operators so all that stuff
comes into our landing zone and then we
have interpreters that know how to map
the information in each one of those
sources into this graph database
currently we're using heal for J as a
graph database
so maps it into these this ontological
framework and then we have apps that can
query that graph database and do a
variety of neat things so what I'm what
I'm about to show you I I have this you
know Astra graph loaded on the next
screen next to me then I'm gonna
actually give you a walkthrough and kind
of disclose more of these problems to
you to get you guys to weigh in on
hopefully so you know get you to think
about a little bit more all right so
what are what are the googles that we
have well you know we want to make space
transparent and predictable because we
have more and more participants on orbit
bad things can happen and it's very
difficult to even a true W you know
cause to any of these things basically
given any body of evidence that we
currently have
unfortunately multiple hypotheses
explain the same evidence and these can
be very different from each other
everything from like I said Jimmy Jimmy
shrekt me on purpose to the son had a
hiccup of energy and that upset my
electronics and in and your courses of
action really depend on the cause of
this anomaly we have these space traffic
needs in the sense that what we put on
orbit isn't randomly scattered and I'll
show you that we have highways and these
highways have no traffic rules none and
so pretty much you get on orbit you kind
of do whatever you want and just hope
for the best and we got more and more
stuff on these space highways and so
again we've developed this kind of
ontology based knowledge graph that we'd
love your help with and and try to find
ways to try to solve that problem so
here we go so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna kind of skip over some of these
these slides I'm gonna put that one up
there before I switch over just because
I love that quote
and let's see if I can go over here and
share this with you if you can see a
planet that kind of and a lot of dots
rotini I want to hear some noise in the
crowd okay so this is you know this is
Astrid Graf kind of visualized and what
you're gonna see here is we're looking
down on the earth and these are about
half a dozen or so different sources of
information that we bring in to this
graph database and it when you go to the
website it just breathe he's up the
orbits but this outer ring that you see
is the geostationary ring and it's a
it's one of the highways I was speaking
about and it turns out that if you put a
satellite at that orbital altitude it
takes that satellite about 24 hours to
go around once which as you know it
coincides with an Earth Day and so it's
the perfect place to put communication
satellite because it kind of stays over
a specific longitude of the earth and
that way you can point your satellite TV
dish and leave it alone and always get a
signal but unfortunately there are a lot
of dots that you see here and only the
ones that are in orange are things that
work and everything else is garbage one
of the things that you can see is this
pink string of pearls and all of these
objects in that string of pearls
were generated from one object that blew
up very recently in the past few weeks
so all that all that string of all these
all these dots right here come from the
same parent object unfortunately one of
the other things that you can see as you
can see kind of a pattern here and all
those came from the same parent object
and you can see an other pattern over
here that also came from the same object
so within the last 12 months we've had
three rocket bodies blow up that have
generated a significant amount of
garbage that now we have to try to avoid
and track so what else is the problem
you would ask well we don't all agree on
where things are located so I'm going to
give you an example here let's see
[Music]
here's an example of some object it's a
planet lab satellite it's in low-earth
orbit and you can see a couple of dots
you can see a number one and I'm going
to pause this really quick let's see if
I can pause this yeah maybe I can't
pause it on yeah here we go alright so
number one is where the United States
Department of Defense believes that
satellite is located right now number
two
is where the owner believes it's located
and number three is where a commercial
radar company believes it's located
those things don't match up with each
other entirely so one of the questions
is why why not and so there's different
assumptions that we have on the physics
there's different assumptions that we
have on the measurements themselves
there are many assumptions that we have
and they they don't all agree and so you
know it's not just the number of objects
up there it's the fact that we don't
even have a consistent picture of
exactly where it's at here's another
example with another planet lab cube set
plot 3 P 8 and so again number 1 is
where the Department of Defense says
it's located number 2 is where the owner
says it's located number 3 is where Leo
labs a commercial radar company says
it's located and number 4 is where I
believe it's located yeah yeah I'm not
gonna lie to you I'm not perfect but
it's just very interesting ok and so
this is a problem that we have as well
how do we how do we bring in
heterogeneous data heterogeneous
information some of it is sensor
information some of it is semantic some
of its opinions some of its tweets how
do we bring all that stuff into a common
framework and make sense out of it to
get a realistic picture of what's fun
orbit you know if somebody were to ask
you how do you know that you have the
world's most accurate clock your answer
might be well because I have hundreds of
them
and you would actually be right because
that's how we tell time on the earth we
have hundreds of atomic clocks cesium
fountains rubidium that sort of thing
each clock has an opinion of the time
and then what you do is you gather all
of these opinions and look for the
centroid of them the weighted
combination of these things gives you
what the tiny standard is so how do we
how do we come to a weighted combination
of opinions of stuff on orbit and as you
probably know if you don't have enough
data it's very hard to tell that one of
the things that is the most difficult
challenge that we were facing and
putting together this graph database is
in generating the schema and the
ontologies I mean one one challenge the
people in the room might be how do you
how do you how do you generate ontology
x' autonomously like if I just have a
bucket of disparate information how can
a computer go in there and basically
read in all these things and sort sort
out different fields and actually
propose what the schema should be
because every time somebody brings me a
new source of information I have to
spend a long time with my staff to try
to comb through that manually to figure
out what does each field mean what does
it represent and how how do I make sense
of that comparing and contrasting
against information that I get from
other folks so that's one of my major
challenges so as you can see things look
a bit bleak here
we do face a tragedy of the Commons if
everybody just wants to behave any which
way they want we don't have any space
traffic rules but we do have space
highways and we don't all agree on
what's on orbit and rent where it's
going and what it is or is it
and so with that what I'd like to do is
I I'd like to open I liked I'd like to
see if there's a possibility they'll
kind of open this thing up for questions
if people can see me so and the question
is whether there's any plan for
collecting micro space garbage yes
absolutely so I think that's an
excellent question
I will say that you're not the first in
line to try to make money to collect
space garbage and one of the things that
we need to do is we need to be able to
find a way to make that something that
you could monetize and in order for us
to do that one of the things that we're
working on is we're trying to develop
what I'm calling a space traffic
footprint and the space traffic
footprint is an analogue to a carbon
footprint as a name kind of suggests and
certainly we're not going to measure
space traffic in terms of you know tons
of co2 but we have to come up with
another metric for that and you can
think of the space traffic footprint as
the burden that any given object poses
on the safety and sustainability of
anything else so so an example would be
when I get into my car as soon as I
start backing up from the driveway
I'm a burden to all other pedestrians
and all other drivers the fact that I
exist
means that somebody else has to take my
existence into account for their own
safety and and so I would want to be
able to ascribe that to every object in
space some footprint some nonzero
footprint of its burden on everything
else because you have to account for it
and once we have that then maybe we
could actually put bounties on specific
objects a ten thousand shekels for
removing this object because it has the
largest footprint or clean that up and
I'll tell you this much or even
insurance companies you know there is
such a thing as satellite insurance they
don't make a whole lot of money now but
boy it would certainly
nice if they could now underwrite their
premiums based on something like a space
traffic footprint so that needs to be
created first in order for you to make
your money so I'm working on
so the question is the example where
things were far apart
how far apart was I was like miles or
inches or feet or what well how far was
that well if I told you millimeters
would you believe it yeah so so we're
probably looking at the largest
distances between things you're probably
looking at hundreds hundreds of meters
to probably a couple of kilometers
yep
so the question was you twice mentioned
tweets as a way to attract stuff hot
what how does that relate yeah so oh so
this is where things get tricky so as it
turns out before things launch before
things launch sometimes you might get a
tweet that says hey you know we we have
Ukraine Ukraine has a satellite they're
gonna launch in two weeks
this so-and-so has a set of binoculars
and they saw some bright light in the
sky at such-and-such time so humans
actually have some information that can
relate to helping you detect track and
even identify objects in space if you
can find a way to link link these
sources of information together
so the question is how much can amateur
equipment help as a data source so glad
that you asked that so so so actually
I'm gonna try this one more time here
and I'm gonna
forget it alright so this are all
information from amateur astronomers on
space objects and it doesn't show up in
anybody else's database and one of the
reasons for that is because
hold on
let's see if we can one of the reasons
one of the reasons for that is because a
lot of the a lot of the data that may
provide our on supposed spy satellites
so these amateur telescope people love
to try to track spy satellites and so
each each one of these is supposedly
something that somebody doesn't want you
to know about so I think that's kind of
cool
you
so the question is what mechanisms
mechanisms do you have for dealing with
malicious or inaccurate information
yeah so this is where more data are
better the more independent sources of
information that I have the more
difficult it is for something to corrupt
the system because it'll it'll it'll it
won't be consistent and so I don't I'm
not at the point yet where it's easy for
me to to say with high confidence I
can't be spoofed but I'm going in that
direction it's exactly why I'm trying to
crowdsource independent sources of
information as many as possible so that
I can look for things that are
inconsistent
how does the privatization of space
helper hinderer York
I'm sorry can you ask the question again
yes how does the privatization of space
help or hinder your work oh I want it to
be as commercial as possible to be
honest with you I want I want space
commerce to thrive it doesn't hurt me
whatsoever and in fact there there are
more and more private organizations
interested in the research that I'm
doing and and one day hopefully we'll
see some space tourism I don't want to
do it but I'll let you go first all
right right here from it's a question is
whether there is a movement to regulate
with treaties or anything like that yeah
so it turns out that the United Nations
has an office of outer space activities
in Vienna and in you and OSA there is
the Committee on peaceful use of uses of
outer space or koklos and I've actually
been on the US delegation to the UN
several times and participated in
meetings where the outcome has been an
adopted set of 21 guidelines that if
implemented would definitely help in
terms of long-term sustainability of the
environment those guidelines are not
legally binding in and of themselves
but if every country that signed to that
about 90 plus countries by consensus
signed to that if each country that
signed to that actually implements that
as space law in their own country and
then try to regulate it that way that
would be quite helpful and so that's the
thing that I'm really trying to motivate
is for all these countries to now pass
that as their own national legislative
framework so that we could see a more
sustainable space environment
alright let's take one more one here
Bret
so the question is what would the
recovery window for an object be like
from meters or kilometers or something
like that
the recovery window I don't even know
what that means so the question is how
good of a good of a tract do you need to
be able to recover an object yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so here's the thing right
I mean maybe at first you just need to
know where something is to within
several hundred meters but then if
you're going to actually rendezvous with
this thing to do some sort of proximity
operation or actually grapple it you
probably need to know where that object
is relative to you to below a meter to
probably like a foot or even less than
that
ok I think that's it for questions do
you wanna wrap up at all or yeah so
here's the thing that I want to say
right is first and foremost I want to
thank you for even trying this thing out
with me and I'm glad that it worked as
well as it did you know I'm not gon
would but I don't speak to folks such as
yourselves routinely and hopefully I've
been able to plant some seeds of
curiosity and some challenges that we
face in terms of being able to harness
all these different sources of
information ways to organize curate this
stuff think of methods of being able to
exploit the information and
the thing is if we don't figure out this
independent way to monitor space we
could very much face this tragedy of the
Commons where some portions of space
become unusable because of collisions
and in just that the gross number of
objects that are going to exist in any
given orbital regime and so we need an
independent way to do this and if we
just wait for governments to do it it's
not going to happen
no single company is good born of burden
this on their own shoulders so we need
folks such as yourselves to to work with
me and trying to solve this stuff and I
thank you very much around here is a
very appreciative and this great talk
thank you